All right. Let's try another little quiz, but this one is going to move our understanding
forward a little bit more. Here's a little bit of Python code.
A subroutine called "countdown" takes an input x.
It executes a statement, and then it goes into a while loop
and repeats these two statements some number of times.
Then when it's all done, it does one more statement.
We can take for any given input--like this print countdown 50--
we could count up the time--the number of statements executed--
for this to execute. It's going to be something like this.
We didn't talk about the number of steps that it take to do a print statement if there's a subroutine,
but we're going to call it one for the print statement plus
however many steps it takes to execute the subroutine call.
In these case, countdown 50--what is it going to do?
There's going to be 1 call there, 2 for each time that it counts down,
which is going to be--what--10 times, right?
It starts off at 50, going to go down by 5s until it hits 0.
There is going to be 10 times that it's executing these two statements.
That's 20--21, 22, and the print statement is 23.
This--if we ask the time that this takes--is going to be 23 units.
Here's the trickier question.
What if we just say we don't know what n is. Someone is going to tell us n later.
We're like to know the number of steps, the amount of time that it takes to execute this formula,
as a function of n.
We can't automatically grade a mathematical function--or maybe we can.
The way that we're going to score this quiz is instead
of you telling me a mathematical expression for this function,
I want you to actually give me a function that takes as input n
and produces as output the number of time steps that it will take to execute
countdown or this entire block of code here.
We already figured out what happens when n is 50, but we want a general form of this.